bonjour bonjour aujourd'hui c'est
l'heure de la vidéo nostalgie une petite
blague que je me réserve est de faire au
moment où on commençait à faire cette
vidéo j'ai des amis on va voir par quoi
on a commencé au d'où l'on vient en
question nos racines quels sont vos
origines car il ne faut pas les renier
il faut les assumer
si je vous raconte ses magasins fermés
ou comme ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui on
faisait des vidéos un petit peu
expérimental un petit peu moins fou et
je sais qu'on a déjà fait une vidéo
comme celle ci il ya un an ou deux je
sais plus mais j'avais envie de refaire
et d'expliquer un petit peu plus ce qui
se passait à l'époque dans la tête donc
tout a commencé par une vidéo de qualité
extraordinaire vraiment les gens et arte
y sont abonnés sont femmes à l'époque à
avec cette intro il ya jean sont
d'accord donc avec cette merveilleuse
intro chanson qui a dû fêter des
centaines de personnes salut à tous sa
soute donc s'excuser on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour 2011 est beaucoup à
connaître cette vidéo c'est là que j'ai
décidé de faire une vidéo
pas forcément un jour ici qu'à l'époque
à l'époque je puisse faire des vidéos
sérieux sur les jeux vidéo et déjà fait
une sorte de vidéo test sur le multi de
crysis 2 j'aime une correction des
couleurs de fils de [ __ ] pour faire
genre que c'était beau donc la démo est
téléchargeable sur steam gratuitement
magasin rapid à jma césar va sentir mais
je suis pas du tout serein je me pisse
dessus au moi je fais cette vidéo c'est
extraordinaire bref on a commencé par ça
on faisait donc beaucoup de call of duty
1 comme 100% des [ __ ] de youtube
heures à l'époque tuto comment faire et
3,60 sur pc j'ai fait ça moi le mec il
savait le moins faire ça au monde j'ai
fait un tuto pour apprendre à le faire
voilà je me cherchais clairement j'étais
en pleine recherche d'identité et me
souviens qu'à l'époque je regardais un
youtuber qui s'appelait pis mode 3
steria qui vivait au québec et qui
faisait des vidéos sur les jeux vidéo
mais en mode drôle détente et avait la
tchatche et ça plaisait énormément donc
j'ai décidé de suivre un petit peu sa
voix est marrante un jeu plus vers le
fun c'est là que bon nombre d'entre vous
m'avez peut-être connu devant les défis
de squeeze voilà où je jouais et à
chacun la jeunesse on vient de loin
[ __ ] c'est ouf car le but c'était de
prendre note du tabasco à chaque mort
est ce qui est marrant c'est que des
années après ce truc est revenu à la
mode ya des gens qu'on refait des vidéos
ou pas sur collectif sur deux jeux ou
des qui mourrait ou quoi il y avait un
truc à faire et non à commencer par sa
[ __ ] ça qui est beau à notre config de
l'époque les gars
c'est ce coup-ci réalité aujourd'hui je
fais cette petite vidéo parce que vous
êtes vraiment beaucoup a demandé mais la
jeunesse la police sans imperfection
puisque je vais terminer un traitement
au curacné le traitement bien hardcore
sa mère qui te dessèche les naseaux mais
qui tu retires tous tes boutons d'acné
u n 30 wahaha 3 7'' pourvu conseille de
prendre une 500 watts 1 550 parce que ça
vaut le coup parce que sinon vous
proposant un peu soit alimenté la gt le
pro pour répéter ce que j'avais lu dix
minutes avant et qui a sauvé était
totalement faux j'étais un butin
d'escrocs
dans les bacs le 7 et que la leçon qu
est ce qui m'avait pris à l'époque
oc malesan doha bombes allaient
couchepin portail dans le temps là comme
dans nos coeurs ce psg prédire le
week-end avant de partir tu habites dans
une maison il est 16h tu une barbie à
personne cherche pas d'excusés faisons
pour mes projets mais c'est quoi ces
vidéos la haye la petite intro à base de
3d que tout le monde avait c'est la mort
d'un et bien c'est tout le monde sait
squeeze et si on se retrouve aujourd'hui
avec ce short de bain sur la tête c'est
pour ces ridicules j'avais envie de
faire ça quand je marque quoi je suis un
beau gosse marseille
alors écoutez j'avais envie de faire le
point
à propos des vidéos à venir et des idées
que j'ai eue alors atteint m'ont dit que
je passe mon oral de français n'ont
jamais vu un mec moins naturel devant
une caméra
bon là on court dans cette vidéo je dis
que j'ai des idées en fait j'en ai pas
eu et je demande aux gens de me proposer
des idées dans les commentaires le grand
classique du tube heures fumée bref on
zappe cette phase ma les antes de call
of duty et de je me cherche on arrive
ensuite à la paris games week 2011
[ __ ] mon gars c'est vieux de ouf
j'étais à l'aise et a vu des youtube
heures j'avais croisé monsieur v12
escorté par une babe du salon voilà
monsieur v12 c'est gratuit et ensuite on
atteint les dix mille abonnés c'est
incroyable dit me la mode ici l'occasion
de faire quoi de faire mon premier
podcast est gêné c'est de le faire sur
les toilettes
voilà ce que refléter bien ma maturité à
l'époque finalement bon récemment on a
fait le cas du trac et à pire vidéo de
la chaîne youtube tous les temps on n'a
pas tant changé que ça finalement
il était là le ton ce qu'ils y étaient
déjà là en 2011
aujourd'hui pour mon tout premier
podcast ap
non ce n'est pas validée par la prod
mais c'est mignon tout plein mais rien à
dire franchement les toilettes c'est
quand même le seul endroit au moins
route et tranquille quoi enfin quand je
dis landreau mi août et tranquille
bref oui désolé presque j'avais pas de
taper sur les cuisses avec les larges et
un problème bref voilà je pense qu'en en
trente secondes on a vu le taux de
malaisie de sud assez élevé mais voilà
je voulais tenter ces fameux sketch en
effet jusqu'à dire chouette modeste et
celui-là il s'était quand même en 2013
ya trois ans donc finalement j'aurais
tenté pendant longtemps de percer là
dedans j'ai dû faire un truc trop mal
aisance et une vidéo sur le trailer dmw
trop j'ai remplacé tous les sons par des
bruits de ma bouche mais bientôt vous
verrez
le local toi le noir à ben ouais je vois
ton oui pour les démarches cette fois je
gagne c'est un supplice mais n'a rejeté
j'avais quoi j'avais 15 ans du coup
[ __ ] je re a été cette vidéo alors
vous allez la voir par vous-mêmes vous
rejoignent les laissons 1011 personnes
qui ont passé là on se cherche encore
ses patrons coiffeurs que tu les défis
de squeeze ont fait un dut battlefield
différents jeux et c'est là que me vient
une idée que je me dis et si au début de
mes vidéos gaming
je faisais une petite intro petit
podcast d'une minute que je suis pas
assez bon pour faire des vidéos entière
de podcasts donc je vais faire un mini
podcast au début de vidéos gaming par
exemple sur le mode d'une bâche chargé
de gaulle duty black ops à l'époque
c'est dur
franchement c'est dur de regarder ces
images mais heureusement ballester v
n'existait pas à l'époque mais il
m'aurait mis direct sur sa chaîne manga
baca real aurait été fini jours mais ça
montre que quand tu commences tu fais
pas du tout voire sont des trucs ou
surtout quand tu es jeune tu aimes
vision des choses un peu différentes
et quand tu vieillis que tu mairie qui
veut dire qu tu t'aperçois que tu
faisais vraiment des trucs bidons mais
je suis content je vous tends d'un fait
ça parce que j'ai expérimenté des trucs
et je trouve que c'est bien expérimenter
des choses et d'ailleurs je vous si vous
êtes ouvert je souhaite d'expérimenter
des choses bond à jouer ces petites
intrigues maurice tic qui est qui et il
goûte un drôle comme vous et moi on
encore non encore un podcast sur les
profs tu découvres tout nouvelle
impulsion était nouveau prof
en plus de ça tu découvre aussi les gens
de ta classe d'ailleurs qui sont parfois
plutôt bizarre excusez moi les mecs
c'est aussi la première pour ce faire le
break
hier j'en ai plein quoi ton beau
parcours la l2 tout maghreb c'est tout
et les toits ça va bien enfin xavi c'est
dur c'est dur c'est dur mais il faut que
ça brille ça c'est nos racines bordel
ces deux là n'ont rien au continu les
podcasts
j'avais déjà fait un truc sur le plage
et à l'époque en 2012 j'adore avec les
gens qui traitent de plagiat c'est que
généralement ils traitent les gens de
plagiaire pour rien autant si tu fais
quelque chose qui ressemble très
fortement à ce que quelqu'un de entre
guillemets connu à fait là c'est super
bien d'accord as tu un supergroupe cette
vidéo il ya des je me mets à la place
des gardes ya juste des photos de meuf
en maillot et to call on me reverra moi
on dirait un mec qui prend des photos à
cachette de filles qui laisse coach
comme ça je vous ai bien dans sa chambre
avril 6 mai de vie sera arrêtée tout de
suite enfin c'est la chance de réussir
la cpc pas moi qu'il faut taper sur quoi
j'ai donc tous ces [ __ ] de deux
podcasts ont atteint les 50 mille
abonnés on est très heureux toujours
puceau maîtresses auront continué vidéos
gaming et à partir de là donc c'était
vraiment 2013 comme à l'époque j'avais
emménager j'habitais à anthony j'ai
emménagé à place d'italie je t'ai
toujours chez mes parents et c'est là
bas que je faisais vraiment des vidéos
sur le même principe de ce qu'on fait
maintenant c'est à dire ben juge ou un
jeu vidéo faire décote faire des
changements de pouvoir ajouter des
effets des trucs mais j'ai quand même
beaucoup moins naturel que maintenant et
c'est différent j'étais plus jeune mais
en vrai c'est là qu'on a commencé à
faire ce qu'on fait encore maintenant
voilà ah bah non ça marche pas du coup
je choisis de mandales et alors ce soir
on assista rinne qui ne sert à rien
voilà dans le ring on peut observer une
poule
bon voilà j'avais j'avais en fait
j'avais moins d'improvisation j'avais
moins improvisées donc comblé par plein
d'effets au montage et puis j'ai fait
mon premier coach est inverse ici oui
absolument une faq un petit peu moins 6
e vous aimez gap lui donne en effet au
total treize ou quatorze je sais plus
avec complètement cartonné à partir de
mi 2013
on était vraiment dans ce qu'on fait
maintenant l'arrivée de l'oculus des cas
un le développement qui tint c'est une
version trop pourri look l'usc était
horrible et à la fin de chaque vidéo je
faisais avec ce truc j'avais la nausée
de malades faisaient un vrai malaise
pendant 30 minutes j'étais tout blanc
allongé sur mon lit je me dis [ __ ]
c'est bon j'ai pris ma vidéo avec
l'oculus ça fait rêver je pense qu'à
l'argent voilà qu on a continué
continuez continuez ensuite il ya eu six
pringuez ming à ce moment là qu'a ouvert
aussi regarder si pringuet mis la
première vidéo c'est vrai yemenia est
donc supprimé on avait refait ce délire
d'intro un petit peu sketch avant la
vidéo gaming est appelé
cyprien gaming franchement c'est nul
squeeze tu sais que tu parles à une
statue des plus tard tu sais ça ouais je
sais ouais ouais tiens j'ai toujours
intacte et incroyable cyprien merci
d'avoir pris parce que généralement pas
très bon voilà du coup j'étais super
content que j'ai pris à me contacter
pour faire 7
cette chaîne secondaire en fait je
passais beaucoup de temps seul devant
mon pc à faire des vidéos sur ma chaîne
a pu aider à faire le montage pendant
six heures être seul comme ça devant son
pc chez toi être tout le temps chez toi
aussi mine de rien jamais trop sortir et
donc ses prémisses m'a fait vachement
bien parce que finalement c'était la
même chose que ce que je faisais mais à
deux espaces qu'il faisait montage en
plus c'était john du coup le cadre
inventaire de spring c'était vraiment
trop marrant et j'étais dégoûté parce
que j'ai pas pu aller à le 3 parce que
je passais mon [ __ ] de bach que j'aime
troisième 8,8 à côté kevin de la jaune
qui a son diplôme d'ingénieur mais bon
un peu de respect pour les grosses
merdes kevin se plaît sur toutes ces
vidéos l'année en 2014 et je pense qu'à
partir de là les a pas grand chose à
dire parce que finalement c'est comme si
on faisait maintenant bon même si
maintenant on a on a mûri et grandi
là-bas tout ça ils m'ont est différent
d'avant mais ouais je sais pas je pense
à dire ça parce que j'ai l'impression
que c'était vraiment fière quoique je
faisais ces vidéos là alors que ce pays
a déjà deux putin d'année
regardez la vidéo qu'on avait la vidéo
comme ça qu'on avait déjà fait mais ya
un an et demi finale chromis utilise
plus de tonner cours au lit les vidéos
sont la colonne âge étaient déjà morts
devant un malaise à les vrais que voilà
je crois qu'on a fait le tour des amis
écouter je suis tout ému massa les
connais je suis vraiment ému de revoir
tout ça en fait de revoir tout
simplement tout chemin qu'on a parcouru
parce que tu sais on est tout le temps
dans l'horreur je trouve dans le
quotidien dans faut avancer faut avancer
vous faire des trucs et on oublie ce
qu'on a fait avant je suis tout ému ça
me rappelle plein de bons souvenirs même
la bazouge ses trucs de merde où je me
cherchais où je voyais que j'avais envie
de faire de l'internet de vivre de ça de
donner les moyens de réussir là dedans
et que et quoi j'ai fait plein de trucs
différents dont plein de trucs pourris
défaut mais soutenu une fois vous m'avez
dit oh attention luc hallade sur une
branche c'est un peu la merde c'était
une [ __ ] aventure youtube et ça
continue cinq ans après presque six ans
en mars afin six ans que le chêne existe
c'est juste incroyable donc voilà je
voulais vous remercier je trouve que 7
millions d'abonnés c'était une bonne
occasion pour faire cette vidéo merci
d'être nombreux à suivre les vidéos en
plus cher jean kévin ne vous plaisent
beaucoup plus qu'avant il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui ont mon âge qui ont 20
piges et ou qui regardent les vidéos et
ça me fait super plaisir que mon délire
vous plaisent ont fait plus de là
merde que jamais cf les vidéo pokémon
mais c'est ça qu'on aime c'est ça qu'on
veut donc merci merci et encore merci
l'on se retrouve pour les lumignons
alerté sa prochaine vidéo merci d'avoir
regardé j'espère que ça vous aura un
petit peu ému que vous avez pas versé
une petite larme non plus qu'après je me
sentirais coupable
si vous avez versé une petite larme
j'espère juste que c'est parce que vous
avez été tellement mal à l'aise de voir
dans cette vidéo que les larmes ont
coulé chat au monde glisse